welcome back another Democrat leader of
a sanctuary state is decrying The Surge
of migrants in his state that would be
California governor Gavin Newsom he is
now threatening Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis with listen to this kidnapping
charges after flights filled with
migrants touched down in Sacramento with
us now the five co-hosts Geraldo Rivera
and Fox News contributor Leo Terrell
thank you guys both so much for joining
us this morning really looking forward
to the conversation on this one
um I want to draw attention to this
tweet that Gavin Newsom put out
yesterday if we can pull this uh Mike
jaw kind of Hit the Floor when I saw
this he tweets at Rhonda santis and says
quote you small pathetic man this isn't
Martha's Vineyard kidnapping charges
read the following the kneeling's
California state law on kidnapping Leo
we'll start with you one Governor
essentially accusing another governor of
criminal conduct suggesting criminal
charges seems like kind of a big deal
your reaction
yeah it's a governor who's lame duck in
California who gets on his knees every
day Bill who wants to become president
and basically he's attacking Ron
DeSantis because Gavin Newsom has
basically destroyed California hey he's
made California a sanctuary City and you
know what's an amazing bill is that he's
complaining about Ron DeSantis Cindy
migrants to California but what about
the El Paso mayor they're sending
migrants oh he's a Democrat this is
nothing more than political
grandstanding every state is a border
state and what Gavin Newsom is
complaining about he welcomes he
welcomes everyone to California and
that's why California is the worst state
in the country Heraldo back in 2018
Gavin Newsom tweeted to president Trump
and basically said that California is a
proud Sanctuary state so your reaction
to this beef going on with him in
DeSantis right now over this this new
flight to Sacramento
well uh first of all bill I think that
we have to rest uh stress what the
governor Newsom said of Governor
DeSantis he called them a small pathetic
man I mean that is an ad hominem attack
that is kind of extraordinary uh but he
also said he was guilty of borderline
human trafficking and uh you know
state-sanctioned kidnapping is not a
public policy Choice it's immoral and
disgusting and I absolutely believe that
there is now the San Antonio district
attorney in Texas a state you know well
bill has decided that it was probably
kidnapping when Governor DeSantis sent
that first batch of Texas migrants to
Martha's Vineyard uh what what in the
world does DeSantis doing getting
involved chartering private planes to
take migrants to these high-profile
locations why just to make a political
point he is using these human beings as
political pawns I think it really is
the leader of a Democrat city mayor
Oscar Lisa in El Paso is doing the exact
same thing he's been doing the exact
same thing bussing thousands of migrants
right here to New York City so where's
the criticism for him
well I I will give it in one second I
just urge our audience to consider this
alternative to this grandstanding and
using human beings as pawns why not give
these people temporary work permits we
have 3.7 unemployment in our country we
are desperate here in Cleveland there
are Help Wanted signs everywhere why not
give these uh Asylum Seekers vet them
give them the Asylum Seekers give them a
temporary work permit so they can pay
for their own way work rather than
welfare why can't we do that why can't
we get together and pass a simple simple
executive order at President Biden
should do this it is his primary
responsibility and shame on the the
president for not doing a vigorous
enough job at this but that's what you
need to do positive thinking Leo go
ahead Bill thank you very much Bill this
is he bill you asked him the same
question I asked the mayor of El Paso's
doing the exact same thing her brother
didn't answer that and that sheriff he's
a Democrat let's be very clear this is
purely political and I want to be very
clear as a lawyer Herald is a lawyer
kidnapping charges where's the evidence
where's the statements from the
individual migrants who said they were
kidnapped or they were misled but all
her others doing right now is drinking
the Democratic Kool-Aid her rather
wanted to tell the fox viewers hey the
El Paso mayor Democrat he sent thousands
and the Democratic Sheriff he's
basically a political Lackey for the
Democratic party answer our questions
please Geraldo no talking points if if
these immigrants are fully briefed on
what their options are in a fair full
way that I have no problem with Texas
officials dispersing them to locations
where they have family where they have
friends where they have contacts not
take them and send them to Malta his
Vineyard or Sacramento California when
they have no connection to those places
this is mean-spirited this is malicious
this is not seeking to cure the problem
this is seeking to hurt and and by
hurting make a political example and
that's why Newsome got off the feet
Trail and said something as as as direct
and as pointed as calling DeSantis a
small pathetic man so look the bottom
line here is people obviously going to
have a lot of opinions on what these
these Governors are doing with the
busing the flights
um but a lot of the migrants you talk to
when you're down there they're not
wanting to stay at the border they got
places they want to go across the United
States none of them are being physically
forced onto these buses or flights to
your point or although some of them are
signing consent forms at least in Texas
so
um you know everybody's got an opinion
on it we got one minute left here quick
30 seconds last final thoughts for each
of you Leo starting with you
thank you very much first of all no
one's being forced as you correctly
stated Bill and again I I don't want to
waste my 30 seconds uh Geraldo the El
Paso mayor is doing the exact same thing
but you have no criticism of him the
bottom line is Gavin Newsom is Bored he
wants to run for president he cannot so
he attacks ad hominemen attack against
Governor DeSantis shame on him Geraldo
very very quickly Governor DeSantis
scored what he thought was a publicity
coup with Martha's Vineyard so he's
using 12 million dollars in state funds
to Charter private planes two groups 120
the other 16 all going to California
because he's seeking another hit and
because he can't he can't live without
the juice as he's running for president
he's in Iowa he's in New Hampshire he's
in South Carolina so why not get some
publicity get a few headlines in a
controversial uh issue that he thinks
the Republican base will jump on his
side this is pure base politics and
shame on Governor DeSantis all right got
to leave it there we think both of you
guys for coming on this morning another
great conversation we'll talk to you
guys soon thank you
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis